Speaker 1: All right. So let's talk about that
on the Clay and Buck show. Newly minted after his
disastrous Twitter announcement. 2024 Republican
presidential candidate Ron DeSantis was on the
Clay and Buck show and he wanted to address the
issue of pardons. And he says no pardon is off
the table up to and including Donald Trump.
This is a couple of minutes long. Let's get
into it. A lot of interesting stuff here.
Speaker 5: Abandoned. A big part of being
president is pardon powers. Do you think
the January six defendants deserve to have
their cases examined by a Republican
president? And if Trump, let's say,
gets charged with federal offenses and you are
the president of the United States, would you look
at potentially pardoning Trump himself based on
the evidence that might emerge of those charges?
Speaker 3: The DOJ and FBI have been weaponized.
We see that. We see it in a variety of context,
some of which you mentioned. Some of it is the
FBI going after parents, going to school, board
meeting. Some of it's how they treat a pro-life
demonstrator, how they don't go after people that
are attacking pro-lifers. And so what I'm going
to do is I'm going to do on day one, I will have
folks that will get together and look at all these
cases, who people are victims of weaponization or
political targeting, and we will be aggressive in
issuing pardons. Now, some of these some of these
cases, some people may have a technical violation
of the law, but if there are three other people
who did the same thing, but just in a context
like BLM and they don't get prosecuted at all,
that is uneven application of justice.
Speaker 1: And so understand the framing
here and then we'll get to the Trump part.
The framing here is we need law and order,
but we can't allow people of different political
stripes, one, to be prosecuted in the other. Not
like if you go after a January six writer, but
not a BLM person. If they did the same thing,
they should both be prosecuted. I agree. The
thing is, they're pretending like there's many
examples of that when in reality there are not.
Speaker 3: We're going to find ways where that did
not happen and then we will use the pardon power
and I will do that at the front end. You know,
a lot of people wait until the end of the
administration to issue pardons. We're
going to find examples where where government's
been weaponized against disfavored groups and
we will apply relief as appropriate. But it will
be done on a case by case basis, because I think
we've got to make sure that because there's
a whole bunch of cases that don't necessarily
get headlines. But if people are being treated
just because they don't get on TV or something,
they're being treated this favorably.
They need to have a fair hearing as well.
Speaker 5: And that could be from a grandma who
got arrested and prosecuted too much all the way
up to potentially Trump himself. Is that fair
to say when you analyze what the charges might
have been brought on a federal level?
Speaker 3: I would say any example of
disfavored treatment based on politics or
weaponization would would be included in
that review, no matter how small or how.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So that that's up to and
including Trump. Think about the argument and
the case the Santos is making. He wants to be
president. He wants to be chosen over Donald Trump
to be President. Trump incited an insurrection
right on January 6th. And rather than coming
out and saying the Republican Party needs to
go in a different direction, I condemn what Donald
Trump did inciting his followers on January six.
But instead, he says, I'd consider pardoning
him. I'd consider pardoning him. Now, let's
put aside the political calculation. The political
calculation I've told you before is he want the he
being DeSantis wants to find some path to appeal
to the people currently supporting Trump so that
they might vote for him. And his calculation is,
if I condemn Trump's role in the riots and the
attempted coup, I'm getting rid of all the MAGA
potential MAGA support. So DeSantis has made
the calculation that he's not going to do that.
But let's step back from the political. This is
a very dangerous and irresponsible thing for Ron
DeSantis to say he is undermining the rule of law
and undermining the accountability of public
officials are excusing public officials from
accountability. Trump is facing multiple
investigations, including for his role
inciting the January six riot, his business
dealings, classified information handling,
pardoning Trump would send the message that
he's above the law and his actions don't
have consequences. And it will only embolden the
extremist elements of the base who participated
in the riots or who supported them or thought
that they were a good thing. DeSantis said he
would also consider pardoning rioters, rioters
themselves, saying, Well, some of them were.
It was a technical violation of the law we call
those violations of law. And when you say, well,
it was a technical violation, but it deserves a
pardon, you're either saying they were justified
actions or that they were trivial actions. And
all that will do is encourage more violence and
encourage the potential for another insurrection.
And it will also, by the way, just deepen the
polarization and the division in the country, too.
Sanders talks about, Oh, I would become a uniter
or whatever he's saying. I will use pardon power
to favor what he sees as disfavored groups who
were the victims of political targeting. It's the
same victim mentality again and again and again.
And when the world sees this, they look at it and
they say this United States, what are they doing
over there? What are they doing? And the Santos
is echoing another mistake from American history.
When President Gerald Ford pardoned Richard Nixon
after the Watergate scandal, that was a mistake
that eroded public trust in government. It
weakened our moral authority. Because it said,
okay, yeah, law and order, except for some vague
unification of the country, we're going to pardon
Nixon. I think it was a mistake. I think it is
a mistake to be talking already about pardoning
Donald Trump. Now, in the meantime, Joe Biden was
asked about pardoning Trump. He just laughed it
off. A security man. All right. You see that Ron.
Speaker 2: DeSantis said that if he became
president, he would pardon Trump. Where are
you on the idea of president pardoning Trump?
Speaker 1: Biden laughs and waves it off. And
this is absolutely the right aunt's answer.
And by the way, I think this is better than
Biden even saying I will not pardon Trump,
because if Biden says I will not pardon
Trump, that will be politicized. Biden
has been handling this perfectly,
which is to say, any time he's asked,
I am not getting involved in any of that. I'm
just not getting involved in even the question,
would you consider pardoning Trump? You say,
Yes, I would. Well, obviously he wouldn't say
as you say. No, I wouldn't. People say, well,
what if the evidence showed it was politically?
Walking away laughing and waving it off is
the right answer. Biden should have nothing
to do with the prosecution of Trump.
And I love that he is staying out of it